se confirmó la condena alexéi navalni
tendrá que cumplir dos años y medio en
una colonia penal una cárcel donde los
reclusos siguen un régimen de trabajo un
tribunal de moscú rechazó la apelación e
hizo caso omiso a las peticiones de la
defensa y del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos de liberar al opositor
ruso algo que la defensa se esperaba
esperábamos el veredicto de hoy lo
consideramos ilegal nada ha cambiado la
condena de tres años y medio se ha visto
acortada en seis semanas además también
han sido descontados los diez meses que
estuvo en arresto domiciliario durante
el juicio de 2014 por lo tanto a navalny
le restarán dos años seis meses y dos
semanas en prisión la justicia rusa le
condena por haber violado los términos
de una sentencia de 2014 que le dejaba
en libertad condicional el tribunal
considera que faltó a las
correspondientes revisiones obligatorias
de la libertad condicional mientras
estaba en alemania recuperándose del
envenenamiento sufrido en septiembre de
2020 además el sábado navalny fue
condenado por otro caso a una multa de
12 mil ochocientos dólares acusado de
difamar a un veterano de la segunda
guerra mundial que participó en un vídeo
en el que defendía que vladimir putin
pudiera postularse a dos mandatos más en
el kremlin después de 2024 el tribunal
acusa a navalny de llamarles lacayos y
corruptos el opositor se rebeló contra
la corte y espero que ustedes que
todavía son jóvenes no sólo ardan en el
infierno sino que también tengan que
acudir a un tribunal humano normal por
lo que han hecho
navalny que cuenta con el apoyo de eeuu
y la unión europea es uno de los mayores
críticos del gobierno de vladímir putin
su encarcelación desató en febrero las
mayores protestas en rusia en décadas